it'd be interesting if they had like
steak pop-tarts and Oh vegetable pop
we're getting I've had a forbidden love
affair with pop-tarts I've never eaten a
pop-tart I have never had a pop-tart I
haven't had a pop-tart in days every
time I go to the grocery store I'll go
to the pop-tarts aisle and just marvel
what the flavors confetti cupcake good
looks like a clown this smells like the
roller rink at an eight-year-olds
birthday party oh good a dying cupcake
someone left a cupcake out way too long
and just fed it to me this was the one
I'm gonna put away
I'm always indifferent about red velvet
yes it's kind of a lie this orange is
like a red velvet cupcake that's pretty
good eating a whole one of this will
give you the biggest stomachache you can
have him as a snack or if you're
incredibly high or something I feel like
I'm gonna get in trouble
my mom smells like a cocoa pebbles
smells like brownie better I'm really
excited that's what I like better than
the other ones
I really am getting nothing it's like
cardboard it's so oh yeah maybe put a
scoop of ice cream on top
didn't I deep-fry my mom is out of town
and my dad's trying to make me lunch
this wasn't meant to be
I like this that's amazing this is
delicious actually it's peanut butter
and jelly you can't get up and they did
it they pick it up this is like Miami
Vice is Pop Tart
it looks like a 90s like bus seat it's
just a flavor that has become a thing
what's the part in pop-tart there's
always something from the fifth element
like hits you up I like it a little bit
more because it's like that finally we
agree on something
mm-hmm oh that woke me up this is it
this is the one that I always wanted
this is the one these are such a big
deal culturally it's like state by the
Bell wait I need to take a picture with
this
huh interestingly enough tastes the most
natural the flora tastes like a creamy
fruit roll-up it reminds me of the good
old days I was never really the popular
kid in school but I feel like I had a
friend come over after school we have DS
and for one little minute there I was
cool I just like can't imagine like the
people that design these and they're
like lab coats and I'm like Jerry we've
done it